listen I like you so I just gotta know I
can can you be in my nice self or I can
be an [ __ ] what are you into Wow you
are beautiful
are you crazy what are you planning on
eating tonight is gonna be expensive I
don't have much money so what have you
heard about me so drugs totally
disgusting I shouldn't bring it up or
they're really fun you wanna hear
stories so how many dates until we have
sex even how often okay so do you know
anything about wine cuz I'm about to
make some [ __ ] up when do I actually get
to meet the real you I gotta be honest I
don't know where you want me to look
that shirt really shows off your boobs
and I appreciate that if I order a salad
are you gonna judge me where do you want
me to look that says I appreciate your
body but still respect you so this whole
nice thing does that last you're really
great how terrifying is your dad home
getting drunk where you at
catch up girl you actually like me or
did you just want to check out this
restaurant so you mentioned it didn't
work out with your ex why hey I'm a
scale of 1 to kill me I'll possess a
click on a scale of 1 to 50 shades of
grey how free here you who are you
texting is this narrative of my trip to
Thailand doing anything for you do you
think your mom material you like kids
right out of everything that I've said
here tonight what is gonna help me the
most on this date how many kids is too
many feeds
straight up are you crazy wow this is
going really well like how many other
people are in love with you right now
are we having sex tonight